what is Freemason I don't understand is
that connected to this or is that
different
mystery is like an open Society
open Society
Society it's veiled in secrecy and they
only reveal the truth to the higher
ranking ones but really it's a
Protestant arm of the Jesuit liberal
order of the Vatican and it comes from
Jewish mysticism in Kabbalah
it's crap stuff like that and um it
pretty much reverse Engineers the Bibles
these rituals it's both and uh it
encompasses all ancient religions of
antiquity all Pagan star systems
um star of rimfin molok and everything
they prayed to
and uh I really have to it boils down to
Osiris right they're obsessed with each
ship and that's why they wear an apron
to hide the generative principle right
talks about
okay so it's essentially it's a it's a
secret
Society
Society they're down the street but the
movers and shakers like Shaq is a
Freemason he's on TV at the ranking says
he's a Freemason they will connect you
to enhance him Pelosi's husband and
teach you where to best
or something like that if you're a part
of the billionaire ruling class of
masonry if you're just a large Mason
it's a little different where most
Freemasons did not saying like 90
they're just kind of in a club they
don't they don't know what the [__]
they're doing
I feel like if there was this Society
like people would know more about it
like I like I just have a hard time
thinking like videos wouldn't get leaked
and like it would be on the front pages
of stuff
well no it's not a secret every single
president admits that most of them admit
that they go to that Temple they don't
go to church they go to a freemasonic
lodge right it's open they admit this
who like Trump
uh Google every president who was a
Freemason openly that talked about it
there's a huge list no way huh
even Trump when you look at millionaires
they look at analytics and statistics
there's a picture of trump pointing to a
cabal his Kabbalah teacher he had a
Kabbalah teacher which is Magic why do
billionaires have magic teachers it's
because they spell cats like McDonald's
has a red yellow
uh low goal to stimulate appetite to
sell more right that's a psychic
programming uh they wouldn't use blue
and all marketing at the billionaire
class actually comes from religion like
what is subbing up it's pointing at the
seven planets of antiquity that they
worship
um even Nike is the Saturn string the
logo right the cabalists worship Saturn
the furthest from the sun because
there's only seven planets in this
version
okay
what do you think it was push you
thought it was just a check I don't know
or look at Marina Marina Abramovich she
got a billionaire uh Bill Gates to
sponsor her and Jay-Z and all these guys
and all she does is blood spirit cooking
art
but you know the billionaires don't do
art for art
right they're actually communicating
with the spirit world that's why uh
Hitler's School Society was started by
Wizards uh you this is all open you can
Google it
um and these people are obsessed with
real energy from the eat they're ups and
and communicating channeling with demons
and in a lot of freemasonic monitors
they talk about
if you've never painted a painting in
your life you can enter a psychic
translate causing a Consciousness State
uh pollution where you kind of
hallucinate and you can do a Mona Lisa
but really you're channeling demons and
they always take over at the end and a
lot of people pop off when you look at
Madonna on a lot of these Stars they're
always doing some kind of magic
what do you mean magic I have I have do
you know people people on Brad Pitt's
level like these kind of names I linked
over 98 uh no
96 celebrities at Brad Pitt status and
money level
just in Hollywood not even politicians
I've linked them all to Freemasonry
Kabbalah Blackmagic there's white magic
gray magic and black magic right but
I've linked all of them and you can even
see the Ukrainian soldiers in Ukraine
there you if you YouTube they do this
ritual where with Earth fire air and
water this is how they do it even Saudi
Black magicians do this worldwide they
all do this it is Ukrainian soldiers cut
bleed into the dirt and light a fire in
the dirt and pray to this big [__]
wooden Pagan God
but if Christ is like the God is
stronger than the devil like why would
they pray to the devil
well it's only for the material world
it's not for Infinity like this is a
this material world is just a blink
Infinity is everything so if you think
about it they're only getting fun in the
material world and it's not regular fun
these people are using their minds
they're going through psychosis if you
look at how much success schizophrenics
have had with exorcists
compared to a big Pharma it's insane
when you look at both studies
uh yeah these people believe that our
fentanyl addict has a dead fentanyl
someone who died from fentanyl their
security inhabits someone else and
that's where they get the impulses the
invisible impulses that Chris Crofton is
like you to make them do more drugs they
don't want to do the drugs but they need
the drugs and yeah that's all in your
documentary so I'm way deeper than Alex
Jones let's go like the video
um are you supposed to be somewhere
right now that chat is
Marty I didn't think we'd be an hour
late to start but it's already done that
I know I've done that YouTube channel
and I don't want to thank you for not
coming to Chicago so you're more
important
for Chicago again okay
um
don't worry okay they're they're putting
it in the chat calling the queen
um wow but that's so interesting huh and
this this is like YouTube friendly they
let you talk about this on here
oh yeah oh this is YouTube friendly
there's people who make a lot of money
talking about this stuff but it's very
low level shallow they talk about
Raptors and [__]
uh they want to know what the biggest
girl you've ever been with is
any hope
every girl I've been with is the same
frame as my ex like because I kind of
get the same body type every time
is there any hope for chubby girls and
obtaining high value men
maybe but not me
[Laughter]
um if you could snap your fingers to fix
the modern dating scene what would it be
Catholic the office
I want and I don't really believe a
woman has to marry an older man I
believe men can be men at 16. they can
go to war at 16. they used to do it for
thousands of years so a 16 year old
woman or a 16 year old girl whatever
would marry a 16 year old boy in my
perfect system and and he wouldn't be
immature he would be you'd be prepared
and he'd be pure and he'd be like
Knights Knights used to not even tell
White Lies that's how religious they
were
yeah they were trying to say that was
bad but you said the 16 year olds
marrying each other but it's like what
good what good does it do they're
thinking I'm [__] a 16 year old
that's why they called me a Pedro
they're like he wants it for himself and
I'm like there's most people in my
movement would want an older guy with a
16 year old I'm not gonna lie but I
think
you can mature if you're in the born in
the right environment you can mature at
16 in Civil War you could be a hunter at
16 easily and you have a piece of energy
and puberty right there
um I don't know who Dawson is but
someone said have you heard from Dawson
lately
oh wait that was the guy in the other
stream right oh right that was that was
the one you that didn't that made you
get kicked
yeah have you talked to him since
no but uh people are saying I should
stop talking [__] about him because
apparently his documentary is made for
me like I'm gonna love it so when I give
it a chance I don't want to have bitter
feelings I just want to enjoy it
uh what is oh yeah why are you going at
the Tates
uh I I did I said I'm having a cold down
to date I do a lot of bait me
meme like tweets and uh it's great
marketing but uh his brother messaged me
he's like I I talked to my brother and
he has nothing scheduled you don't work
and I'm like dude I got canceled
defended these guys when I didn't even
know if they were human traffickers I
just went off the content of their
character that they're not I defended
the [__] out of these guys or protect
them my family loves them or my brother
and me so it really stung and I'm not
the type of guy who goes they don't know
who I am because they're very tapped in
they watch everyone on the internet like
they're as paranoid as me so I'm like no
they're they're really just taking a jab
because I went on a fresh bid and
they're like oh this guy's gonna affect
their bottom line maybe he'll take 10 of
our money and I'm taking all of it [__]
plus I don't really want to have thio
allies
that's all I'm going to say what's
what's Sido allies what's that
what
Zio allies I don't want Zion what is a
Zio what's a Zio Ally
um protecting your channel what the [__]
oh
you think they're okay I'm gonna just go
on to the next one um he sold himself to
something only if you will understand
it's not Satan some have realized that
um this guy is smart look in his eyes
dbf
um
I I think they're calling you smart
I don't know what is what is your next
uh move with podcast uh content
I just see what my team sends me they
just send me addresses and locations and
times and I do it but really
um the only time I change my schedules
if I know someone like you or if I
snaked You by not coming to Chicago but
uh yeah I just go off with what they do
because if I do the backhands and stuff
I quit like I've quit the every time I
got relevant on the internet I quit I
was like did my own thing and I was
dealing with a lot of personal stuff
there and now I really can't quit
because uh I'm not 80 with God I'm like
100 on board now and so yeah I feel
great but I don't really know what's
next I just know there's
I don't want to leak it should I leak it
if you want
the grilling girl wants me on
oh oh you would be amazing on there
no I know they're okay they won't I I
know I know um standout TV they're not
like I've been on there before not with
her but like with the guy version of
that
they're not
like they don't care so I know I know my
community is going to say clear your
schedule for that one they want that
yeah they all come to London I'll put
you on shows for like a week
oh hell yeah I'll stay tuned two weeks
then if I get work yeah I don't want to
build no I want to do others I can I can
you we have a whole streaming room too
like I can let you stream too
I can make a dollar looks full yeah yeah
that's what I was like I wish um I wish
you were closer I'd help you with a lot
of the the stuff you're because you're
talking about needing an editor and
stuff I'm like I have basically
everything you need
yeah yeah no I have a bunch of people
who help me it's just I don't get on
calls like I save all my energy for a
stream and then I spend four or five
hours alone in dark I don't talk to
anyone I don't do anything and then I
sleep so that's my whole problem is like
I don't want to communicate with my team
I don't want to be a business you know
which is kind of tragic I could have
made fifty thousand dollars Justine told
me this week if I just but whatever I
just focusing I want my I just want the
relevancy and then my documentary that's
it have you ever attended a traditional
Latin Mass
oh
no not a traditional one I went to my
first uh Sunday mass last week and then
uh and today I was hurting bad so I went
to church
this is the second time and it feels
great
I mean I don't belong there I'm not
gonna lie there's a lot of Shame like
I'd be looking I don't make eye contact
with people in church because I feel
like you know in circles in church you
know and it's weird like I take my hat
off because it's disrespectful but I
don't want people to see me in there you
know I get really ashamed why Catholics
are nice
no it's my past is very sinful and how I
live right now is not that great I mean
it's way thousand times better than my
past but it's yeah yeah but have you
ever gone to confession
no oh my gosh you should
well you know
I'm gonna I'm gonna be baptized this
year 2023
okay you've never you didn't get
baptized in like a different
no
you're you're I've never done anything
I've never done anything religious
oh okay
um yeah
I went to a Protestant Church once and
they just made me play basketball and
I'm like this is not for me bro uh yeah
Protestants it's really interesting
because Protestant like the way a lot of
non-denominational churches communicate
it's very similar to feminists I can't
unsee it I argue with them on Twitter
all the time
like like the way they like weaponize
being a non-believer if you have any
criticism of them it's very it's very
similar to the way like feminist
weaponized sexism
yeah yeah well I would say 90 of
churches pastors and Priests are
compromised I don't like to say that
but uh
yeah it's become a lot more of a liberal
World well they don't ever preach
against female sin they only preach
against male sin it's like it's really
weird once you see this you can't unsee
it it's like I mean maybe you're pretty
like tuned in
I mean when a woman sins it's the fault
of the man in the community you know
women can only be bad because Men Let
Them women by Nature aren't that bad
um but when men are just like leaving
them alone and letting them vote and be
equal that's when they go whoa you
abandoned me now you end in my chaotic
nature how could you and then they
rebelled right but really women act very
good in that
spiritual Society they are very nice
why do you think the women are so bad
and bad in church because the men don't
hold them accountable or what
you mean like Catholic school girls who
are all [__]
um I think that I mean I just
sorry go ahead
MTB which is Masonic television from a
masonic temple I think it's stronger
than the church to these women right
because uh you know they they're growing
up in a world where they feel like men
are just going to cheat and leave them
so
they just lose their minds and uh start
becoming hoes
and they're not wrong because most men
are simps like I feel bad that women
have to date these kind of guys
you know I've had shy girls and crazy
girls say the same thing I said I'd
rather have a guy who beats me than a
sin
when they were done their same face they
start to hate the sins right
like they're wasting their youth on
but like I always say to a girl why you
should be extra feminine around me is
because you're getting the most
masculine channel on the internet in
your bedroom
playing video games with you and
chilling with you you must be so aroused
and I'm getting 50 percent
feminine no if I'm a cartoon you're
gonna be a cartoon what the [__] as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible